it was such an honor to get to work with
such tremendous actors I mean Susan
Sarandon George Lopez like these
household names I was so honored to be
you know kind of sharing the screen with
them and I can say you know similarly
I've gotten the chance to work on COBRA
Kai for the past bunch of years which is
like an intergenerational parents can
watch with their kids and I'd say this
takes that to an even new level you know
and and although it's you know Latino
and this and that it transcends
ethnicity and I think you know black
brown Asian whatever you are that you're
going to be a that going to see yourself
in the whole family for sure that's
amazing what a great answer yeah I can't
I you going to love the movie I can tell
you that love it love it your sister my
sister is yeah this is